[Música]
tem uma frase que habita a minha vida e
ela surgiu quando comecei a trabalhar na
televisão
eu sou jornalista sou apresentadora é
uma frase que me deixa muito feliz que
finca meus pés no chão mas me deixa
apreensiva em alguns momentos até
paralisada
é difícil um dia que eu não ouça ou nas
redes sociais ou principalmente mesmo
uma pessoa negra falando pra mim você me
representa
você me representa
é uma responsabilidade sem representa um
país racista
num país com mais de 200 milhões de
habitantes metade dessa população
auto-declarada negra e parda e que é
racista e nós somos muitos
somos muitos no país racista quanto
somos hoje
nesse auditório negros e negras quanto
somos hoje no ted x nova lima
eu me represente é algo é difícil mas é
um gatilho importante para eu pensar na
discriminação do país e eu penso nisso
todos os dias porque eu sou negra tô
vivendo pensam disso todos os dias e
penso nisso ainda é tendo esse gatilho
apontado pra mim mas também é uma
alegria ao mesmo tempo sabe de todas
essas pessoas é falando comigo eu fico
feliz é um momento de afeto entre os
iguais é o momento de abraço de beijo
porque depois do você me representa
sempre tem uma história sempre tem uma
história gente sempre há uma história
por trás é vdd
você me representa a minha família se
reunir para ver você
na televisão a gente fica junto à
família negra
que alegria gente eu fico super feliz
porque eu fico imaginando essa família
negra e aparecendo eles vibrando por mim
aí tem uma briga pelo controle remoto
tem conversas paralelas tenha feto tem
acolhimento é uma família podia ser a
minha família pois essa é a sua família
podia ser muitas famílias poderiam ser
muitas famílias aquelas que aparecem até
no comercial de margarina é o de
supermercado
mas como é uma família negra esse
exemplo não sabe por que a gente não tá
no comercial de margarina e no comercial
do supermercado
isso acontece muito pouco isso é raro
dá até a impressão que para existir na
mídia que para existir na sociedade
brasileira é preciso ser branco para
existir é preciso ser branco para
existir
não é preciso resistir resistir a partir
do afeto também essa família
me traz afeto de você me representa
agora é um adolescente que está falando
pra mim e ela me conta a minha mãe me
chama toda vez que você aparece digitar
na televisão é uma mãe negra
essa mãe negra sabe o quanto é difícil
não se vê em nenhum lugar o que é isso
pra filha dela não quer que a filha dela
forte empoderada ela que a filha dela
maior do que aquela se apequene nos
papéis determinados da sociedade
ela quer que a filha dela quebre
paradigmas roupa ela quer que a filha
dela apareça que a filha possa sonhar em
ser e quem ela quiser ser médicas e
dentista 7 vista ser doméstica
mas o que ela quiser se apresentadora de
televisão e aí nesse caso eu represento
o desejo que nós mulheres negras
temos de ser plurais
nós somos diferentes como vocês todos
são diferentes aqui nós somos plurais e
esse desejo está representado
e essa preocupação dessa mãe é uma
preocupação que tem sentido tem sentido
essa preocupação e essa preocupação está
fazendo com que as gerações seguintes
sejam mais fortes porque eu percebo
jovens negras hoje não é tão fortemente
na mídia tradicional mais invadindo
totalmente as redes sociais na internet
elas conseguiram que elas não se viam
representadas e os seus cabelos não
estavam lá se as roupas que elas vestiam
não estavam na moda criar um blog
elas começaram a se comunicar
tá se fortalecer fortalecer a identidade
se formar enquanto mulheres negras
enquanto jovens negras shoppings nem que
estão arrasando o olho muito pra elas
não é da minha geração uma geração a
minha geração um pouco mais cuidadosa
elas são cuidadosas ela chega parando
tudo e elas podem fazer isso não quer
dizer que elas não queriam um espaço na
mídia tradicional e elas vão atrás disso
inclusive porque a repercussão delas é
na internet faz com que elas voam em
mais alto de sempre representa aí é um
pai querendo tirar uma foto
eu ea filha de você me representa aí é
uma mãe que me abraça e no meio do
abraço ao começa a chorar porque na
verdade o que ela quer dizer que o filho
dela sofreu discriminação na escola e
voltou chorando pra casa não sabe como
lidar com isso
sabe onde você me representa tem uma tia
com uma sobrinha e aí ela olha para os
brindes assim está vendo o cabelo dela é
linda igual ao seu
aí eu lembro da minha infância eu tenho
44 anos essa hora para vocês falarem 1
obrigada a passar a infância na década
de 70 e 80
eu sou da zona leste de são paulo da
periferia de são paulo
estou me sentindo em casa porque minha
mãe mineira meu pai é baiano os dois pra
são paulo trabalhavam na roça foram pra
são paulo pra melhorar de vida
a minha mãe foi cozinheira foi doméstica
parou de trabalhar quando se casou e
criou as quatro filhas em casa curtindo
a gente
meu pai trabalhou na construção civil
entrou na construção civil começou a
trabalhar cedo que tinha de criar os
filhos os pais filhos e também os irmãos
ele era o irmão mais velho e virou
mestre de obra depois um pequeno
empresário conseguiram dar uma vida
digna para a gente fosse fui muito feliz
muito feliz brinquei muito casa cheia
casa própria que pra quem cobre isso é
ótimo te dá uma tranquilidade
freqüentando a escola
sem nenhum problema em casa
só que os meus pais não discutiu a
questão racial nunca foi discutido na
minha casa isso a questão racial e aí
ele quer fazer uma crítica aos meus pais
eu só quero é pensar em como isso deixou
marcas em mim porque eles tiveram a se
esforçar muito para me dar uma educação
de qualidade para colocar a educação
como prioridade isso me fortaleceu com
certeza
só que isso não me brindou do
preconceito eu tenho as marcas até hoje
sente a menor
me sentia inadequada
não gostava da minha boca não gostava do
meu cabelo não era bom seneme não era as
minhas referências na televisão toda a
maioria será que é por isso que eu quero
seja aquilo que me tornei jornalista
será
é fora cantoras de pessoal do sport
nenhuma referência a irmã mais velha dez
anos mais velha que entrou na
universidade
foi uma referência forte pra mim mas nas
novelas
as atrizes faziam papéis que não faziam
com que eu sonhasse mais alto não minhas
bonecas todas brancas loiras de olho
azul todas inclusive nos anos 80 c loira
era algo que pareciam um pré-requisito
para você ser apresentadora de tv e aí
as crianças assistindo àquela
apresentadora que é algo mais cruel e
mais simbólico do que o sonho de uma
menina negra e ser paquita é algo que
ela não vai conseguir é um padrão que
ela nunca vai alcançar e é isso que as
meninas negras vivem todos os dias e é
por isso que a gente tem que dar espaço
pra elas pra todos
a gente não pode ser invisível a gente
não é invisível tem uma história a de
diá outra de semi representa é seu herói
que me representa um é que sei lá 12 13
disse me representa obrigado por botar
essa cara preta na tv ele pode falar
vocês não hein
e aí eu me lembro de uma história com
mano brown que é o líder dos racionais
mcs
quando entrevistei ele pela primeira vez
eu cheguei toda feliz a preparada não
tem duas cadeirinhas no camarim ele
estava saindo do show saiu com um um
grupo de amigos em volta dele eu fui
cumprimentar e fui me apresentar wilson
adriano metrópoles placa lá eu te
conheço preta tive fiquei feliz porque
vou fazer entrevista da minha vida
humano brawn me conhece
olho no olho nós dois preparada pra isso
até que ele vira para todos os amigos e
dizer ei pessoal vamos botar a cara
preta na tv todos eram 15
como assim eles se posicionaram em torno
do ano brown fique pra qualquer lugar
que a gente apontar se a câmera a gente
pegava o mano brown mais um carinho
atrás mas é isso aí é guerrilha
resistência é isso mesmo é para botar
todos esses moleques na tv
juntos estamos vivos diria kl jay que é
o dj nacionais também mas aí eu completo
estamos vivos mas a duras penas período
colonial no brasil
agora voltei no período colonial no
brasil e essa história eu devo a uma
escritora que se chama ana maria
gonçalves
existiam muitas leis segregacionistas
uma delas é impossibilitava que negros e
mestiços tivessem cargos civis militares
eclesiásticas us e aí quando um negro ou
mestiço era muito apto para aquela
posição para aquele cargo é algo que
você quase não consegue esconder ele
tinha uma alternativa podia fazer uma
declaração que ele pedia encarecidamente
que eles não levassem em conta o defeito
de cor
defeito de cor quando me vejo sozinha
nos lugares nas universidades na
televisão parece que o que eu passei por
essa lei
o defeito de cor e eu não quero ficar
sozinha eu não quero ficar sozinho quer
muitos eu não quero embranquecer para
participar de alguma coisa a gente tem
que olhar para o lado
olhem pro lado a gente não pode mais
admitir essa ausência na sociedade
brasileira e não é a ausência só física
é a ausência das questões que são
importantes para que a gente se torne um
país mais igual e mais justo
e esse caminho passa obrigatoriamente
pelas questões do povo negro brasileiro
não dá para a gente discutir o país não
ouvindo o povo negro é impossível então
sim eu represento algo precioso potente
maravilhoso que é a cultura
afro-brasileira e cada negro e negra
desse país e também me representa
em qualquer em quaisquer funções médicos
advogados em quaisquer funções dentro
das prisões
um menino negro na rua que leva tapa na
cara da polícia ele representa uma
travesti negra assassinada me representa
uma mãe solteira no limite das suas
forças para criar os seus filhos sem o
olhar do estado e representa porque
todos nós juntos somos uma família
a família de diferentes mas somos uma
família eo nosso legado o nosso legado
não é a escravidão o nosso legado
passado de geração para geração
é o sonho da liberdade ea gente vai
mudar o mundo
[Aplausos]